first of all thank you to this panel
this has been such a thought-provoking
day I've really really enjoyed it thank
you all for coming thank you to the
panelists and to the moderators in
particular I've been extremely struck by
how the issues raised today are
extremely analogous to a host of other
issues at the intersection of the public
interest of new technologies of new
business models and questions about
intellectual property we're asking
questions about the future of books
similar questions we could have asked
today about the future of journalism or
about the future of digital education or
about the future of video internet video
of television programming and movies so
these are all incredibly interesting
questions and they're about really the
kind of world that we want to live in
what kind of access to knowledge will we
have in this world what will our civil
liberties be while we're accessing this
knowledge and this is not just civil
liberties in the traditional sense but
our right to innovate our right to
participate in culture a right to
participate in political spheres so this
has been extremely interesting these are
all issues that we address in the Yale
is P so I think this might be a good
time to thank some of the members of the
ISP who have made this possible so
there's a lot happening up in the
balcony you haven't seen that people our
fellows have been coming and going all
day and blogging and running things
operationally we've had people sitting
up front managing panels and managing
just I won't even tell you all the
details because I am definitely not
responsible for this it has been a team
effort so I want to thank a few people
first let me just thank the program
committee can we have them stand up if
they don't mind Ted by field Charles
Cronin Blair Kaufman and oakerson Doug r
and Leah shaver Camilla tubs and Michael
Zimmer there's Camilla in the back and
Michael is over there and a special
thanks to Michael because he was a yell
ISP post-doctoral fellow before he
became a professor at the University of
wisconsin-milwaukee and this project
really originated with some of the
research that he was doing and some of
his work with the new york public
library so thank you Michael for that
we've had a huge yes let's thank Michael
and we've had quite an operational team
from the technology side to the
operational side is Jason I samin here
Jason stand up he really helped with the
video aspects and some technology Debbie
Sestito worked registration this morning
Leah shaver has been doing everything
today and she's up in the balcony now is
still working Lauren Henry if she could
stand up in the front duh grand Anjali
de la who had to leave earlier Julia son
event one of our fellows also & M Alonso
is in the balcony working away Thank You
Emma Adi Kamdar and Daniel is in the
back daniel silverman Chris Suarez is up
there too there's really a party going
on Janice ha and Julia Sun Oven one of
our newest fellows in the front repairs
Grove so we really have had a lot of isp
people here go ahead and start that but
I want to single one person out so this
guy right here is Perry Federman who is
the administrator of the information
society project and I really want to
thank Perry because he does the work of
ten people we have a lot of conferences
at Yale Law School and somehow the other
conferences have ten administrators
working and Perry just does it all and
makes it happen and I think probably
every single person in this room has
emailed Perry probably several times and
then he's done so much work I can't even
begin to thank him so thank you very
much Perry and finally I'd like to say a
word about a tradition within the Yale
information society project and it has
to do with our symposia in this
tradition is that the conference doesn't
end with the closing address it goes on
we wouldn't want to have it if it just
stayed in this room so what are some of
the things that we expect to come out of
this well we certainly believe that some
relationships have been forged here that
will result in joint research that will
result in joint advocacy and other
projects in fact we will have a 5 30
meeting in room 120 that
brewster kahle will lead about new
business models and new models for the
the distribution of electronic books and
storage of electronic books so things
will definitely continue I would also
like to say as this movie plays behind
me and we might have to cut the lights
when we're done just so you can see this
because it's it's really interesting
that we will have a good online resource
associated with this I've been very
impressed with all of the postings today
those who have organized birds of a
feather sessions i encourage you to add
your summary comments and tell us what
happened in those different sessions i
stopped in a few and i think they were
extremely worthwhile now why do I have
this up here well let me first say that
one outcome of this event will
definitely be an edited volume about the
future of digital library so that will
probably I hope that it will go in our
new information society series that the
MIT press is running so we'll have that
but look at this video it reminds me of
a quote the worth of a book is to be
measured by what you can carry away from
it and this conference will be measured
by what you can carry away from it I'm
also reminded of another quote a good
book should leave you slightly exhausted
and this conference has definitely
definitely left us completely exhausted
so what you see in this video it's
called librarians parade let's cut the
lights just for a moment and then we
could close up and then nap and then
leave this is a film it's from 1930 and
it shows Yale librarians look how many
there are what they're doing is they're
moving the 1742 collection of books from
the old library which is now Dwight
Chapel to the newly completed sterling
Memorial Library and it's incredibly
interesting I just wanted to leave you
with this books have always been in
motion these are books in motion they
continue to be in motion and in flux and
i'll just leave with the question of
where will we carry the books now and
who will be carrying them so thank you
very much for coming and
I hope to continue this dialogue